kate middleton and prince william go
from the red carpet to holding some
creepy crawlies in no time flat
after dazzling on the red carpet in
london on tuesday at the world premiere
of the new james bond movie no time to
die prince william and kate middleton
stepped out in northern ireland on
wednesday for a planned official visit
the duke and duchess of cambridge
arrived in dairy londonderry to meet
with some young people and hear about
how their organizations are helping
communities in the area kate looked chic
in a purple emilia wickstead pantsuit
with a black turtleneck a sleek ponytail
and black heels while prince william
looked dapper in a navy jacket blue
collared shirt and skinny tie the
couple's first stop ulster university's
mcgee campus
the royals spoke with nursing students
in person after calling them on zoom
earlier this year to discuss their
experience studying during the pandemic
the couple also visited the campus
petting zoo which is designed to promote
student well-being william held a large
snake while kate held a tarantula named
charlotte yes
charlotte like the pair's six-year-old
daughter
later things got a little bit cuter when
kate got to pet a little chick
the couple also sampled local food and
drinks including some wheaton bread and
[Music]
of whiskey this all comes after a
star-studded night at the bond premiere
[Applause]
william kate prince charles and his wife
camilla chatted up celebs like anna de
armas rami malik phoebe waller bridge
and even mr bond himself daniel craig
how do you get used to it i don't know
billy eilish and her brother and
frequent collaborator phineas also made
it across the pond for the big event
[Music]
billy sings the movie's theme song no
time to die which the siblings co-wrote
can't wait for the bond song one word to
describe
[Music]
bond i don't know okay it's gonna be
bond it'll be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play the royals night out follows an
eventful weekend for prince william's
younger brother prince harry and his
wife meghan markle who made an
appearance at the global citizen live
benefit concert on saturday night in new
york city to promote global vaccine
equity
and while in this country and many
others you can go almost anywhere and
get vaccinated billions of people around
the world cannot as for how the brothers
are doing after the fallout stemming
from harry and megan's bombshell
interview with oprah winfrey in march
well they continue to have a strained
relationship and it remains unclear
where or when we'll see them reconcile
the relationship between harry and
william is still very much one of
distance and i don't just mean physical
across the atlantic but they just aren't
talking that much you know that's
exactly how sources close
to william have put it you know there is
still some feelings of anger there over
the way in which the couple
sort of carried out their departure from
their royal lives and you know i think
for william that's something that he
clearly hasn't been able to come to
terms with yet
[Music]
you